quel pokémon pokémon pokémon c'est
l'heure des paquets des mômes avez
sûrement remarqué que ça draine beaucoup
croquer bones est pas alors il ya
quelques jours en fait se sont déroulées
à paris les championnats de france de
poker c'est fini oui de mort qui fait
pour la première ne peut rien faire on
regarde mes trois catégories d'âge plus
de 300 participants et pour chacun le
même objectif devenir champion de france
de pokémon
mélanie est venu de belgique pour
participer et pour elle le championnat
plutôt pas mal commencé
trois victoires en quatre matches pas
sûr pourtant que ce soit suffisant pour
se qualifier pour la suite de la
compétition
tu te sens comment mélanie ça y est le
classement est affiché mélanie et des
autres joueurs se précipitent pour les
résultats alors alors ouf mais le plus
dur commence à partir de maintenant les
matches se jouent par élimination
directe
ça veut dire que si mélanie perd un
match le tournoi est fini
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
mélanie est la seule fille qualifiés et
c'est donc déjà la meilleure du tournoi
mais c'est un truc de garçons les
pokémon ou quoi
bah oui mélanie se reconcentre elles
viennent passer un nouveau tour
va-t-elle encore avoir de la chance
mash up contre ratatat topic heures
contre salamèche pour les joueurs
l'essentiel c'est de sauver les points
de vie de ces cartes est bien sûr
d'affaiblir celle de son adversaire mais
là manifestement pour mélanie ça part
mal
ah oui c'est perdu ouh là là elle est
déçue mélanie mais bon ça fait quinze
ans qu'elle joue elle se débrouille déjà
très bien
lui c'est vrai elle réfléchit vite elle
a de bons réflexes et il manque juste un
petit peu d'expérience encore quelques
bonnes parties
et puis toute façon ça c'est sûr
et pour être encore plus forte elle a
déjà commencé à échanger de nouvelles
cartes
bon ça y est ça y est t'es tellement
viendrait l'année prochaine car dieu
merci